hey Dan hello I missed two episodes of
game show it needs this week I don't
know what's been going on well lucky for
you Jess it's Friday and that means
there's five stories of the week coming
your way
fantastic Jess Ubisoft back this week
not having a good time for leaks though
no I mean fun for us not so fun for them
we may have found out what next
Assassin's Creed protagonist looks like
which is interesting and it may also
allude to where it's gonna be set even
though nothing's been confirmed there is
a t-shirt a promotional t-shirt that's
appeared online and it appears to show a
protagonist called by yet and there are
hieroglyphics above his name so maybe
it's gonna be set in Egypt there was a
rumor a few months back that that's
where it was gonna be set there's been a
whole bunch of other settings thrown
around maybe the British Museum maybe
the British Museum but uh yeah he's
holding a bow he's got a hood people are
happy about that we'll have to wait and
see reckon a3 is gonna be the time just
to have a license
I don't but that doesn't keep me from
driving in video games that's true and
you'll be able to drive in Memphis
speeds latest sequel Need for Speed
payback there's going to be heist
missions car battles police pursuits and
apparently jaw-dropping set pieces I
don't know what that means maybe you do
like it's a really big jumps and it's
coming to ps4 Xbox one and PC on
November 10 there's a campaign to which
is going to give you a gripping story of
betrayal and revenge probably that's the
name payback but it's set in the
fictional world of fortune Valley and
you'll be playing as Tyler Mac and Jess
great name and they're all three of them
are after revenge on the cartel called
the house watching cities probably uh
something with casinos lost the house
it's all very clever I'm gonna have the
deepest car customization in the series
and a betting system that lets you wager
how well you're going to do in certain
races that's pretty sweet
if you preorder you get the Platinum car
pack which comes with five cars and if
you're an AI or origin access number you
get access to the game on November 7 and
if you preorder the super premium
edition you can get on oh you can get
access three days earlier and also that
premium our car pass so those looking
forward to shadow war win for some not
so great news this week it's been
delayed been off for too long just from
August into October 10th so it's not too
long to wait as per usual with these
things develop Amala said that it's been
delayed so they can improve the earth
will experience when the game does come
out so hopefully it's a good thing I'm
interested to see how it fares though
because it's moving into a very crowded
release window it's after destiny
afternoon and before call of duty yes I
was hoping that it'd come out around
August cuz there's not that much in
there but I guess we'll see how it goes
at the same time I think the fans will
make time for games are excited about so
we'll have to see just we're sharing a
magic carpet count aren't we yeah the
one that's been most successful with
gold-colored is that right
the gold one is the most special one
there's a fact with many things you know
what yeah maybe the new ps4 same is
coming out and gold might also be the
most special one that's pretty exciting
so gold is this not like solid gold gold
coloured I'm pretty sure it's just it's
just gold colored plastic surely come on
when they made a gold console and it was
very extensive we very have at least 80%
all that happen it's a gold version of
the ps4 slim that's going to apparently
launch on June 9 and it's according to
an image that's been leaked by read by a
retailer so classic retailers it's gonna
include a one terabyte hard drive
usually you could choose between a 500
gig or one terabyte but this one's going
to come with one terabyte and it's
unclear whether this is going to be a
region specific color so hopefully it
does make its way down here but honestly
it's gonna be green and gold for comes
in Australia right you think so jeans
PlayStation Plus games were officially
announced after a previous leak but it
turns out the league did hold water
that's a confusing sentence as the games
do include life is strange and Killing
Floor 2 ps4 on Vita you're gonna get me
on Chrome and spy chameleon and they're
both on ps4 as well via crossfire and on
ps3 you get abyss Odyssey and World
Rally Championship 5 so from Broome I'm
excited ooh burn out mmm oh this my hand
need to say hello to you because it's
the outro it is the outro and that will
be the last time you'll see this part
for at least three weeks but not us
because we are back on Monday but we're
gonna be in San Francisco and then the
week after that we'll be at e3 so you're
gonna get all the news that you crave
yes so hopefully we should be expecting
a lot of interesting things gearing up
to the e3 week but a be sure to stick
with us hit that subscribe button if you
like the episodes from this week and
I'll see you soon
[Music]